Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich hoffe, du bist gut angeschnallt.
Das bin ich und viele werden sich erinnern, wie das damals bei der Einführung von Sicherheitsgurten, beim Auto in den siebziger Jahren war, wie unerhört sie das fanden und heute ist selbstverständlich.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die hundertdreizehnte Ausgabe
und wie ihr merkt, geht die Sommerpause in der Mieterebene langsam äh zu Ende. Ich stoße jetzt auch mal wieder dazu, nachdem ich ja äh letzte Woche hier äh nicht nur ersetze, sondern geradezu in Schatten gestellt wurde mit einer hervorragenden Ausgabe
dem äh Herrn Bürmeier, genau, den Richter, der äh ausnahmsweise mal kompeten,
euer.
Die ganze Zeit mit euren,
vergessen? Scheiße, ey.
Kompetente Aussagen hier zur juristischen Fragen, ne? Sehr schöne Sendung. Äh fast wer zweimal angehört zu werden. Aber ähm ja, es geht ja, es geht ja voran, ne?
Es geht weiter mit der Tagespolitik.
Genau, es geht weiter in der Tagespolitik, vor allem man merkt's, dass die Bundesregierung so langsam äh erwacht und sie will uns.
Sie will uns endlich geben, was wir schon immer haben wollten. Stimmt's? Habe ich im Internet gelesen. Alles wird total.
Agenda.
Alles wird total toll. Also sechsspurige Internetautobahnen und so.
Fünfzig Imbitchspurig.
Huhu.
Aber kommen wir gleich zu. Weißt du, was ich ganz schön fand bei der digitalen Agenda? Kommt kommt die Bundesregierung, sagt, wir stellen dir die digitale Agenda vorne. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wer stellt die denn vor? Wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Internetminister? Erinnerst du dich an die Debatte, ne?
Ja. Gibt's ja verschiedene zur Auswahl.
Genau, nämlich Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel von der SPD,
Innenminister Thomas de Maizire von der CDU und der Minister für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur Alexandra. Meine Güte.
Alexander Dobri.
Ja, der macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob er mir so zum Pflicken von Schlaglöchern da irgendwie zuständig ist.
Alexander Dobrindt von der CSU. Und alle drei waren da. Alle drei waren da. Man dachte erst.
Koalition komplett vertreten, ne?
Ja, genau, da alle drei Parteien da, dann können sich alle etwas von diesem von diesem Meilenstein der Politikgestaltung dann da mal äh mit auch ans Revers heften,
und sie sind einfach vor die vor die Menge getreten, vor die vor die jubelnde Menge und haben dann gesagt, wir wollen. Also wir werden dafür sorgen, dass äh Deutschland IT Wirtschaftsstandort Nummer eins wird,
Das digitale Wachstumsland Nummer eins.
Und, und der Verschlüsselungstandort Nummer eins.
Ich habe ja die Veranstaltung nicht gesehen, muss ich sagen. Äh sickerte nur das ein oder andere durch. Das ist doch wirklich krass. Was.
Höhepunkt kommt nämlich noch, der Höhepunkt kommt nämlich noch. All das ohne den ausgeglichenen Haushalt zu versauen. Ne, also mit anderen Worten, die Kohle, also ohne Mehrausgaben.
Finanziert sich quasi von selbst.
Nicht ganz, also für einen Teil soll dann tatsächlich Geld äh also seine signifikant Geld in die Hand genommen werden. Das ist ja schon angekündigte Breitbandausbau. Äh weil sie nämlich in eins, zwei Jahren wieder Frequenzen verhöckern,
den siebenhunderten Megaherzbereich, wenn ich mich jetzt recht entsinne,
und ähm die Erlöse daraus, ja, also diese Frequenzen werden ja versteigert
An Maisbieten versteigert. Bei den äh GSM-Frequenzen so gewesen, bei den UMTS-Frequenzen so gewesen, bei den 4G äh Frequenzen so gewesen,
Und ich glaube, diese siebenhundert Megahertz, die sind dann auch äh äh noch vier G, vier G, geht ja dann irgendwie auf auf.
Genau, für G geht irgendwie überall. Ich erinnere mich auch noch an diesen schönen Ausspruch von äh dem damaligen Finanzminister Hans Eichel,
nach der Versteigerung der UMTS-Frequenzen. Ja, das liegt da noch dran. Äh,
dies Jahr recht, recht, wie soll ich sagen, ähm also da ist ja extrem viel Geld bezahlt worden, das war ja damals noch so eine Highflher-Phase, wo sie irgendwie alle nicht äh genug kriegen konnten,
und äh dazu befragt zu dem Ergebnis, äh meinte er, ja UMTS heißt äh unerwartete mehr einen Namen zur Tilgung von Staatsschulden,
Ja, das.
Ist schön. Ey, aber.
In diesem Fall eigentlich auch wieder sein, ne?
Im in der Retrospektive. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie viel die geboten haben. Ich weiß, dass das enorme Summen waren. Aber mal, wenn du mal zurückblickst damals, als es noch kein UMTS gab, ja, dabei gab's ja eigentlich auch kein vernünftiges ähm,
Internet aufm Handy. Und wenn man sich heute den Markt anschaut, äh den Leuten irgendwie Bits auf ihre auf ihre Handys zu zuschieben, dann ist das so ungefähr der einzige noch halbwegs verbliebene, der irgendwie attraktiv,
ist, ja
den der Markt ist irgendwie größtenteils kaputt. Ja, also da geht's noch ein bisschen Geld, ja, aber was was ist jetzt heute so eine so eine Flat fürs Telefonieren? Was kostet die neun Euro oder sowas?
Naja es ist ja auch sagen wir mal von der Bandbreite her einfach auch kein relevanter Teil mehr, ne? Und die ganze Technik ist ja einfach vorhanden und funktioniert und das ist halt ganz klar, dass das jetzt so Commodity wird, ne.
Ich ich denke nur gerade daran zurück, wie wie damals so diese drei Güte, wie viele Handys wollt ihr denn verkaufen? Wie viel, ne? Oder aber letztendlich so dieses Internet aufs Handy, äh hat sich ja dann doch durchgesetzt, ne.
Langsam los, ging ja langsam los. Alles nur am Rand, also diese drei, diese drei großen Ziele werden also vollmundig angekündigt und dann äh benennen.
Warte mal, IT-Wirtschaftstandort Nummer eins. Haben sie auch irgendwie gesagt, auf welchem Platz sie sich gerade wenn?
Nee, weiß ich nicht. Äh vielleicht ist haben sie das dann auch wieder verbunden mit Bleiben oder nee, obwohl nee, da kann man nicht bleiben, sagen, das weiß ich. Also,
Das sind doch alles nur so Schlüsselworte. Warte mal ab, also du kannst jetzt nicht. Tim, wenn wir, wenn wir jetzt die digitale Agenda besprechen wollen, oder kannst du nicht bei jedem das jetzt irgendwie hinterfragen, weil wir haben hier irgendwie zwei Seiten. Ja, da ist nicht Einheit, da ist nicht,
ich will mal nur so.
Gar nicht wahr aber ich möchte doch glauben.
Gestern, ich habe mir wirklich gestern das äh diese ganze Webseite da durchgelesen. Übrigens, das war auch schön. Es gibt eine Webseite WWW digitale minus Agenda Punkt DE,
Ähm und dann habe ich die so äh gestern dann mal so mit ein paar Leuten geteilt, habe gesagt, guck mal hier, ne, Webseite, digitale Agenda, kann man,
alles nachlesen und dann kriegte ich irgendwie so eine Antwort wie ist doch voll der Fake, bist du darauf reingefallen? Das könnt ihr niemals ernst meinen. Du Idiot, du Depp.
Und dann irgendwie so nach ein paar Minuten stellte sich dann raus, doch genau, meine Ernst, ist die Webseite von der Bundesregierung. Die wurde von einer
Agentur, äh Init oder so heißt die, für die Bundesregierung angefertigt, um die digitale Agenda zu bewerben, hatte ich mich falle noch nicht auf irgendein Haks rein,
Aber okay, kommen wir zu den sieben Handlungsfeldern der äh der digitalen Agenda. Ähm.
Was ist denn das für ein, ja das ist ein totaler Bunti. Hä? Okay, ja. Wahrscheinlich.
Da kannst du das alles, wir klicken uns.
Er ja diese Entwicklung der Webseite hat wahrscheinlich wieder genauso viel gefressen wie man bräuchte um irgendwie Berlin ja zu mit Glasfaser zu verkabeln.
Ja so in der, in der Richtung. Aber ich würde jetzt gerne zu den sieben Handlungsfeldern kommen.
Oh, die sieben Handlungsfelder.
Genau, die sieben Handlungsfelder, ne? Man merkt da, da da kommt der Berater raus, ne? Wir müssen entweder drei, fünf oder sieben sein. Ähm digitale Infrastruktur, ja, kann man sich direkt was drunter vorstellen, klar,
zwar schon angerissen das Thema. Digitale Wirtschaft und digitales Arbeiten, ne? Da sieht man dann auch schon so die Zukunft. Innovativer Start.
Digitale Lebenswelten in der Gesellschaft gestalten? Bildung, Forschung, Wissenschaft, Kultur und Medien.
Sicherheit, Schutz und Vertrauen für Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft.
Und als letztes, europäische und internationale Dimension. Das sind so die sieben Handlungsfelder, in denen sich jetzt diese drei Ziele äh erreichen lassen werden,
über die digitale Infrastruktur haben wir eigentlich schon alles gesagt. Bis zweitausendachtzehn sollen wir flächendeckend fünfzig M mitbekommen und diese Erlöse äh.
In welche Richtung?
Weiße doch down.
Das ist doch wirklich albern. Da reden die von digitalem Arbeit.
Aber das wäre gut, wenn man zu sagen so ey, was ist hier mit meinen fünfzig Mbit-Up?
Ernsthaft, ich meine das das, das ist das, was fehlt, ne?
Ich kenne deine ähm ich kenne deine,
dein deine Meinung zur Bandbreite und so, das auch muss wir müssen aber leider auch echt einfach mal anerkennen,
dass wir hier in einer äh in einem Traumversorgungsgebiet leben von Deutschland, ja und und wir sind schon selber nicht besonders glücklich. Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie mal so ein bisschen in ländlichere äh ländlichere Regionen gehst, da hast du sofort
so was wie in sechs Mbit Vertrag mit fünfzig Prozent wo du dann irgendwie drei Mbit äh,
bekommst, wenn du Glück hast und die Sonne scheint. Und irgendwie ein paar hundert Kilobit äh hoch.
Trotzdem, trotzdem brauchen die fünf.
Das ist die Lebensrealität, das ist die Lebensrealität der Menschen Tim.
Trotzdem müssen die halt fünfzig Megabit ablegen kriegen. Das ist ja genau der Punkt.
Ja, natürlich.
Also nur weil's jetzt total scheiße ist, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass man nicht irgendwie das fordern sollte, was einfach erforderlich ist. Es ist echt zum Heulen.
Sie sollen bekommen, so Internet wie in Berlin, ne
die ganze Trümmerhaufen hier. Internet wie in Berlin flächendeckend bis zweitausendachtzehn. Halte ich trotzdem für kaum zu äh erreichen. Aber jetzt finde ich's sehr interessant,
warum brauchen wir da überhaupt äh Erlöse von der von den Frequenzauktionen, um das zu erreichen? Man würde ja meinen, dass das der Markt schon regelt, ne? Wie er sonst ja auch alles regelt in in Sachen des Internets, ne, also ich meine,
Regelt ja der Markt. Warum sollte der Markt jetzt nicht die Netzausbau regeln?
Weil stellt sich raus, es gibt finanziell nicht lukrative Bereiche und die müssen wir subventionieren.
Oh, wirklich. Welche denn?
Und dann nehmen wir dann, ja, also wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich alle, wo es bis jetzt noch nicht äh ernst zu nehmendes Internet gibt. Also,
Brauchbares Internet, sagen wir mal ernst zu nehmen gibt's ja gar nicht, aber brauchbares nicht. Und das heißt, da werden dann diese äh Frequenz,
Auktion veranstaltet, ne? Wo ja dann wahrscheinlich ehm ein Teil des Zuschlags auf jeden Fall die Deutsche Telekom erhält,
dann bezahlt die Deutsche Telekom für diese Frequenzen. Ja, oder für die Nutzungslizenz dieser Frequenz,
Und dann nimmt er, nimmt er äh nimmt die äh den Bundesregierung das Geld entgegen oder der Staat.
Und dann sagt er so, und jetzt bau mal schön in den Ländern aus und gibt denen das Geld dann zurück, damit die dann den Kunden in ländlichen Regionen ein besseres Dienstangebot machen können.
Finde ich, also ist jetzt, ist natürlich eine kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Also.
Letztendlich sagt man der Deutschen Telekom, ihr kriegt zwei zum Preis von einen. Ja, ihr ihr kriegt diese schönen, neuen, äh, Frequenzen, die ihr haben wollt,
und ihr kriegt auch noch einen schönen äh Breitbandausbau aufm Land. Kostenlos dazu, weil dann wird der ja auch lukrativ. Das heißt, dann haben sie zwei lukrative Sachen auf einmal.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist halt immer so ein bisschen dieses Prinzip Hoffnung so äh es wird so ein bisschen verpflichtet so, ihr macht da so ein bisschen LTE, ja, dann dann äh schwirren da auch tatsächlich irgendwelche LTE-Frequenz, weil von von Kabel auf dem Land redet ja hier sowieso keiner mehr, ne? Ja.
Man sagt ja, ja, hier LTE ist ja fünfzig Megabit, dann ist ja schon alles super, ne? Und ähm,
es muss sozusagen nur äh äh das Wirren in der Luft präsent sein,
die Verträge, die man dann darüber abschließen kann, in irgendeiner Form mit sehr fünfzig Megabit Realität was zu tun haben, so Stichwort nach zehn Minuten ist dein Datenvolumen verbraucht und so weiter. Ja, das äh steht ja dann nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Darüber wird halt hier nicht viel gesagt. Und äh vor allem wissen wir auch
wenn dann die Telekom meintest du jetzt eigentlich gerade, dass nur die Telekom Geld kriegt oder.
Nein, nein, nein. Äh das war jetzt mal nur ein Beispiel, ne. Also bei der bei der Telekom ist es halt offensichtlich. Natürlich werden die die Frequenzen nicht nur an einen
äh Anbieter äh verkaufen und sage ich mal der der Punkt ist nur, wenn du ein Anbieter bist, der beides macht, dann hast du natürlich was davon.
Wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal ein Anbieter bist, der kein,
Festnetzangebot hat. Uch, schau an, zweitausendvierzehn wird es nur noch geben. Äh äh Telefonica, also E Plus und O2 zusammengelegt. Die haben ein Festnetzangebot,
dann wird es äh Vodafone geben, die haben Festnetzangebot und dann wird's die Telekom geben, die haben Festnetzangebot. Das heißt, alle drei potenziellen Bieter auf die neuen LTE Frequenzen haben auch Festnetzangebote
Das heißt, egal, ob die da jetzt, wenn die da jetzt Geld reinschieben, können die auf jeden Fall profitieren. Das Beispiel gilt also nicht nur für die Telekom.
Ich meine, ist ja auch in Ordnung, ist ja gar nicht schlecht, wenn Politik halt so gemacht wird, wenn man sagt, okay, ihr äh ihr kriegt,
Eine Möglichkeit des Schritts in die Zukunft. Dafür müsst ihr aber sehr viel Geld bezahlen. Und das Geld kriegt ihr dann nachher wieder, wenn ihr den zweiten Schritt in die Zukunft tut. Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht mal, ob ich das besonders schlecht finde, ja. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall keine
keine Politik, die jetzt die Wirtschaft besonders stark bei ihrer Verpflichtung nimmt. Oder also die Telekommunikationsanbieter da besonders stark.
Das gab's ja in der letzten LTE-Runde im Prinzip auch schon dieses Ding mit ihr müsst ja erstmal den ländlichen Raum ausbauen und so weiter, aber es ist jetzt nicht gerade so, dass wir das Gefühl haben, dass der littliche Raum total aufatmen würde,
Gott sei Dank, die digitale Dividende, wo wären wir sonst, ja? Äh de facto ist da halt nichts benutzbar.
Also die Waldleute wollen trotzdem einfach schnell das Kabelnetz haben und kriegen's nicht. Und äh diese LTE Angebote sind halt nicht in der Lage, das wirklich auszugleichen, weil die einfach äh vollkommen sinnlose Volumentarife haben.
Ja jetzt bist du auf auf sehr viel, also,
du, du entdeckst hier einen wichtigen Punkt, weil es kann gut sein, hier steht nirgendwo was, das hat durch ein Kabel oder durch ein Glas geht. Aber hier steht sowieso nirgendwo irgendwas, ja? Also da das wirst du im Laufe äh dieses äh,
dieser Debatte noch öfter merken. Aber es geht äh es geht natürlich wieder um eine digitale Dividende und nennt's auch digitale Dividende zwei. Wir schaffen zusätzliche Anreize für Investitionen in den Breitbandausbau.
Als hätten sie auch so gerne digitale Almosen nennen können, weil sehr viel mehr wird's wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein. Äh was mir halt,
generell äh fehlt, hier ist einfach so ein bisschen der Mut, auch mal wirklich so eine staatliche Infrastruktur aufzubauen, die vergleichbar ist mit den Autobahnen.
Wir reden aber hier nicht von Mut.
Nein, offensichtlich nicht, aber äh man kann die da,
mal einfordern so, weil das äh letzten Endes gerade das, was auf dem Land, also ich meine, jetzt ein bisschen LTE und ein bisschen fünfzig Megabit. Wir wissen alle, nach welchen Daten raten wir im Jahre zwanzig achtzehn schreien werden?
Nicht fünfzig Megabit. Und von daher ist es einfach immer noch hinterher. Und ich meine, wir reden hier von fünfzig Megabit, wo du irgendwie in Tokio äh für zwanzig Euro dein Gigabit bekommst.
Es ist einfach so dermaßen beyond, lächerlich. Äh da fällt mir fast gar nichts besser ein.
Ja, also es stimmt. Ja, natürlich. Also es ist jetzt kein, kein, nicht besonders mutig und es ist irgendwie eine, es ist auch kein besonders heres Ziel, dass er also vor vier Jahren hatte ich.
Vor vier Jahren hatte ich wahrscheinlich noch, nee, Quatsch. Vor vier Jahren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob ich vor vier Jahren sechzehn oder fünfzig er mit hatte.
Vor vier Jahren hat sie sechzehn.
Wahrscheinlich sechzehn, ja. Ja, ja, stimmt, ungefähr. So, da war ich jetzt auch nicht mit besonders zufrieden, ne? Und dann kann man ja so ungefähr sagen, das heißt, das ist dann so
hoffentlich noch das sechzehn Mbit von zweitausendachtzehn. Wenn wir Pech haben, ist es das das äh das das sechs Mbit von zweitausendachtzehn. Diese fünfzig MB.
Ja, also es ist es ist eine totale äh Kimäre, die da äh durch die Straßen getrieben wird. Aber gehen wir mal weiter. Was wollen sie uns denn noch alles Schönes verkaufen? Digitales Arbeiten, wir dürfen jetzt richtig arbeiten.
Digitale Wirtschaft und digitales Arbeiten. Ja, da haben sie dann also,
Da geht's dann so um so Sachen wie sie wollen die Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft unterstützen und vorantreiben.
Da steht nix, also da muss man auch mal schneller drüber gehen, das ist ein ein reines Bingo. Sie wollen die junge digitale Wirtschaft unterstützen, nämlich die Gründung von heute circa zehntausend jährlich kontinuierlich auf circa fünfzehntausend jährlich steigern.
Wenn man jetzt mal nur schaut und sagt wie, ja, dann sagen sie, weil sie werden nämlich den Gründergeist in Deutschland stärken.
Oh. Äh das wurde ja Zeit.
Junge digitale Wirtschaft.
Na Beiräte, jetzt holen sie aber schon eine Keule raus.
Sie wollen matching zwischen etablierten Industrien, mit mit Startups unterstützen. Also und sie wollen gezielt Gründerinnen unterstützen, um dafür zu sorgen, dass mehr gegründet wird.
Und sie wollen die deutschen Startups mit anderen internationalen Gründerhabs vernetzen. Also.
Ob die das nicht selber können.
Also ob dir das nicht selber können, ja, also das ist das ist alles so ein so ein null. Das ist dann irgendwann steht nochmal Green IT, Energiewende und Green IT voranbringen,
Wir brauchen intelligente Netze und die Modernisierung von Verteilernetzen, das ist Green IT, ja?
Denn wir werden uns auch beim Einkauf von IKT Produkten stärker an Nachhaltigkeitskriterien orientieren. So, das ist ja alles killefit, das ist doch alles,
Ich habe das irgendwie, ich habe erst diese Kritik gelesen, dachte so, ja, das ist alles Wischiwaschi und es ist alles wischiwaschi, ja?
Da ist nicht ein nicht ein konkreter Gedanke drin. Und das Schöne an diesen Formulierungen ist, die kannst du ähm.
Biegen wie du.
Immer sagen, ja haben wir gemacht.
Ja
Also der dritte Bereich dann der der innovative Start.
Jetzt geht's aber los.
Und da, da kommen sie dann, da, da wäre ich jetzt, da sagen sie nämlich, sie wollen die Abhängigkeit des Bundes.
Von globalen IT-Konzernen reduzieren, beziehungsweise wo immer möglich vermeiden,
ja? Das könnte, da könnte man natürlich so eine ähm.
So eine ähm verdeckte Snowden-Reaktion sehen, ne? Dass sie sagen, wir wollen ähm,
irgendwie nicht mehr mit den globalen Konzernen, global heißt ja, global ist ja äh auf so einer Ebene dann das das Gegenteil von national, ne?
Sie wollen national stärken, einheitliche Standards, größere Interoperabilität, dafür entwickeln wir einen Regelwerk ja ähm.
Ja, es ist halt der typische weichgespülte Sprich, ja, es wird unterstützt, es wird irgendwie äh darauf gedrungen, es wird irgendwie angeregt, es wird irgendwie angeboten, äh ja.
Innovative Unternehmen werden unterstützt, weil sie nämlich jetzt ihre die öffentliche Beschaffung wird nämlich jetzt stärker innovationsorientiert ausgerichtet,
Das heißt, sie wollen noch mehr darauf achten, dass das innovativ ist, weil dadurch äh unterstützen sie innovative Unternehmen.
Gott. Ich entwickle ein Magengeschwür.
Und was ich besonders geil finde, ist in diesem innovativer Staat. Sie wollen auf jeden Fall eine sicherere Regierungskommunikation sicherstellen.
Danke, danke. Okay, es kommt nachher auch noch mal was zur sicheren Bürger äh Kommunikation, aber das finde ich auch sehr schön, dass man sagt, mit dem,
Also du kannst jeden Satz da rausnehmen. Mit dem,
Netze des Bundes stellen wir eine ressortübergreifende Kommunikationsinfrastruktur mit erhöhtem Sicherheitsniveau bereit,
auf die, die drei Ressort übergreifenden beziehungsweise Bund Ländernetze IVB, IV, BV, BVN, sowie DUI, vollständig migriert werden,
Als Integrationsplattform für alle weiter Verkehrsnetze der Bundesfernverwaltung,
und ich will einfach weiter dienen kann. Also das hast du echt nur so da ist nicht eine konkrete. Wobei das wäre jetzt sogar schon mal konkret. Sie wollen drei bestehende Netze auf einer,
Netzinfrastruktur migrieren. Das wird bestimmt ein großes, großer Sprung sein ins in ins nächste Jahrzehnt.
Total innovativ auf jeden Fall.
Sehr innovativ.
Innovativ muss dann die Gesellschaft selber bleiben bei dem Themengebiet digitale Lebenswelten in der Gesellschaft gestalten. Das ist das ist ganz besonders gut,
Also, digitale Lebenswelten in der Gesellschaft gestalten ein schönes Handlungsfeld der digitalen Agenda, denn sie werden,
den Dialog mit Gruppen verstärken, den den Dialog mit gesellschaftlichen Gruppen ausweiten.
Ja, sie wollen sogar eine Debatte mit uns ruhe führen. Uns, wie wir zusammenleben wollen.
Genau das und sie wollen natürlich auch ähm,
den den äh also den Dialog mit gesellschaftlichen Gruppen verstärken, Medienkompetenz und Teilhabe wollen sie stärken,
Demokratie lebt nämlich von Teilhabe. Da haben wir Glück gehabt, dass sie das erkannt haben. Und natürlich wollen sie Chancen für Familien und Gleichstellung stärken.
Ja
Weil man kann dann nämlich äh Arbeitsleben, Familienleben und Freizeit flexibler ausbalancieren. Dank der Digitalisierung. Jeder, der schon mal
Diensthandy hatte mit E-Mail, der weiß, wie flexibel man da diese drei Bereiche äh ausbalancieren kann. Das ist sehr schön. Äh und die Bundesregierung will natürlich, dass möglichst viele Menschen diese Chancen nutzen.
Und was ich sehr geil fand, das, also was ich wirklich schön fand, da habe ich gedacht, Juhu, da schreibe ich einen Antrag. Habe ich gesagt, digitales Engagement möchten sie fördern. Und da habe ich gedacht, digitaler ist Engagement, habe ich. Habe ich, kann ich,
könnt ihr fördern, ne?
Ja, das Bürgerschaftliche Engagement sogar.
Genau und da sagen sie ähm es gibt nämlich einen großen Bedarf am gesellschaftlichen Engagement im digitalen Raum,
etwa oder habe ich gedacht, ja jetzt und was? Jetzt beim Jugendschutz und der Unterstützung von Senioren und Senioren.
Ich mein, ich fände das jetzt wirklich, muss man jetzt auch mal nicht immer nur so, ich fände das natürlich wirklich gut, wenn dir das irgendwie feuern würden, ja?
Also zum ich meine der naheliegende Witz ist natürlich jetzt zu sagen so, ja dann sollen sie halt irgendwie Handys mit größeren Tasten oder sowas, ne, aber die ähm,
Ich meine, das wäre natürlich, wäre das nicht echt, es wäre doch toll, wenn man jetzt sagen würde, du wirst irgendwie staatlich geförderter Seniorentrainer, ja? An, am Internet. So, da wird sie dann da auf ähm, sage ich mal, mit, mit, mit,
Alter, möchte jetzt auch niemandem zu nahe treten, aber das Risiko ist natürlich, wenn man jetzt dann noch so so eine Hardcore-Digitalisierung nach nach äh mehreren,
Jahrzehnten der der Abstinenz erfährt, dass man dann da irgendwie noch halt auf irgendeine Spam-E-Mail reinfällt. Und da ist das vielleicht auch gar nicht verkehrt, wenn da jemand neben einem sitzt, so von der Bundesregierung geförderter,
digital engagierter.
Bürger,
Ja, es ist alles, es ist halt alles, es ist halt alles total weich gespürt und es kann halt alles mögliche heißen, ja? Also es ist äh gibt's eigentlich irgendwas konkretes, was sie genannt haben?
Nein, nein.
Gar nichts. Ich habe irgendwas gelesen von sie wollen die Störerhaftung äh für Privatleute erhalten oder war das in diesem Kontext überhaupt nicht äh genannt worden.
Es war, glaube ich, die Leute, die da nicht konkret drin, aber es gab da schon mehr Lesarten zu dem Thema. Ähm aber um,
Also Digitalisierung, dann Bildung, Forschung, Wissenschaft, Kultur und Medien. Das ist natürlich ein Bereich, ich meine, das ist der einzig wirklich wichtige, ne. Du kannst jetzt also, wenn du sagst, du machst Infrastruktur.
Und Bildung, Forschung, Wissenschaft, Kultur und Medien, ja? Das sind so, was ist das überhaupt für eine Kategorie? Aber so ähm, sag mal, du, sag mal, konzentrierst dich mal auf Bildung,
das sind nur Bildung und Forschung. Ich würde ja sogar sagen, dass äh Kultur und Medien sich in in direkter Folge dadurch dann auch,
ergeben, florieren werden, wenn du in Bildung und Forschung investierst, ne. Forschung und Wissenschaft weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, was der Unterschied dazwischen sein soll. Ähm das wollen sie also äh das muss ja auch äh digitalisiert werden, ne?
Und da wird dann äh wird da würden mir jetzt echt viele Ideen einfallen, wie man so eine so eine Bildungspolitik,
So eine so eine Bildungspolitik mit digital und dann halt so eine Infrastrukturausbau. Ich glaube, das ist alles, was du als Nährboden brauchst,
vielleicht äh täusche ich mich aber das wäre jetzt so meine,
Hypothese. Da sagen sie ja, die wissenschaftlichen Informationsinfrastrukturen werden gestärkt, ausgebaut und besser vernetzt. Was sind denn die wissenschaftlichen Informationsinfrastrukturen?
Das sind doch wahrscheinlich die Glasfaseranbindungen, die die Unis sich vor zwei Jahrzehnten gelegt haben, als es losging mit Internet, oder?
Kann sein, keine Ahnung. Sagen sie ja nicht.
Da kann man nochmal immer nochmal draufklicken. Vielleicht finden wir da noch was zu.
Übrigens, wir haben ja für für alle Hörer, wir haben ja ähm wir müssen sowas ja lesen. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob ihr das auch hören wollt. Ihr könnt ja dann den Skiputt drücken. Aber wir schauen noch mal weiter. Die wissenschaftlichen,
Und das nennen sie sogar unter das das titeln sie mit den digitalen Wandel in der Wissenschaft forcieren.
Ja, es äh ich meine, wir bewegen uns immer noch in diesem selben weichgespülten äh äh Bereich, ja. Es wird.
Ja, ja, wir sind ja auch noch bei dem gleichen Thema digitale Agenda.
Vernetzt. Ja, aber es ändert sich ja auch irgendwie gar nichts. Also alles wird irgendwie toller. Alles wird irgendwie schöner, größer, breiter, sicherer.
Hat schon mal einer in der Agenda vorgestellt. Also Tim, hat schon mal jemand eine Agenda, mir die erste Agenda, die mir so einfällt, wäre so die Agenda zwanzig zehn. Hat da hier einer behauptet, dass irgendwas schlechter würde, als sie vorgestellt wurde?
Nee, das nicht, aber ich meine, da waren zumindest konkrete Maßnahmen mit verbunden. Über die kann man natürlich jetzt äh getrennt der Meinung sein, aber äh die wurden ja dann zumindest auch benannt. Also nicht, dass ich jetzt die Papiere damals gelesen hätte, aber,
Das hier ist einfach nüscht. Also ich meine, da da ob das jetzt existiert und vorgestellt ist äh oder nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht, was passieren soll. Ich meine, das sind alles absolute Selbstverständlichkeiten.
Man will irgendwie äh sich einbetten, europäisch und international und man will ja irgendwie auch überall dabei sein und mitwirken und stärken
und verbessern und einwirken und unterstützen und
Ja, natürlich will man das. Ich meine, das, dafür ist Politik da, das muss man irgendwie jetzt nicht, da muss man nicht nochmal eine hunderttausend Euro Webseite zum Klicken aufsetzen dafür
um das zu vermitteln, ja? Die übrigen.
Nein, aber hier ich würde hier noch gerne noch einen Punkt anbringen, weil sie sagen zum Beispiel hier, sie wollen den digitalen Wandel in der Wissenschaft forcieren. Ehrlich gesagt, genau, also.
Die Universitäten, wenn man die jetzt mal als die Wissenschaft bezeichnet, ne? Das sind, glaube ich, schon die Institutionen, die den digitalen Wandel am ehesten noch in irgendeiner Form vollziehen oder vollzogen haben,
ja? Und was sie hier zum Beispiel sagen, ist ähm sie wollen ähm.
Eine wesentlich zur Weiterentwicklung der Informationsinfrastrukturen beitragen. Und was meinen sie mit Informationsinfrastrukturen?
Archive, Bibliotheken, Forschungs- und Publikationsdatenbanken. Vor wie vielen Jahren hat Google angefangen, einfach jedes Buch, was sie finden, zu digitalisieren.
Ja? Das ist so, also ich meine, da dat kannst du streichen. Da kannst du dich darum bemühen, einen Rahmenvertrag mit Google zu bekommen für dein Land,
aber da brauchst du doch nicht mehr jetzt irgendwie äh Archive Bibliotheken oder sowas äh zu digitalisieren. Wobei das natürlich.
Man müsste das schon tun, aber es ist es wird ja nicht getan, also es ist vor allem dann äh wenn solche Systeme auch entstehen, wo es jetzt hier die Ansage mit irgendwie äh das Wissen allen zugänglich machen, ja?
Wo ist hier die Unterstützung einer äh sich öffnenden äh Publikationskultur im im Wissenschaftsbereich, ja?
Doch das sagen sie. Sie sagen, wir werden die Rahmenbedingungen für den ungehinderten Informationsfluss insbesondere in der Wissenschaft verbessern.
Ja, das kann man so lesen. Ja.
Sagen sie, woher werden sie verbessern? Verschlechtern kann man das ja auch kaum noch.
Ja, eben. Das ist echt zum.
Damit aus Innovationen, Markterfolge werden, legen wir unser besonderes Augenmerk auf eine durchgängige Wertschöpfungskette von der Grundlagenforschung bis hin zu Transfer und Verwertung. Na vielen Dank,
Ich meine, das ist genau diese diese ganze Nummer mit dem ähm dass jetzt irgendwie Leute nur noch so so Deppenabschlüsse an den Unis kriegen, ne. Wie heißt das, Bologna, ne? Das waren jetzt nur noch Bad Bachelor kann's jetzt machen.
Ja, wenn man Bachelor ist, dann darf man irgendwie im Fernsehen, darf man dann irgendwie sich eine Frau aussuchen oder so was.
Also, das, was ja an den Universitäten passiert, ist, ist eigentlich, es gab früher so Fächer wie ähm die gibt's wahrscheinlich heute immer noch. Da hast du sowas äh studiert wie,
Literaturwissenschaften, Kulturwissenschaften und Journalistik. Ja,
und dann war sie irgendwann so, na, das haste dann fünfzehn Semester gemacht, hast dabei ein ein inspirierendes Leben geführt, dich mit vielen Menschen ausgetauscht und dich genau,
Sekunde darum geschert, irgendwo,
Teil einer Wertschöpfungskette zu werden, ja? Und hast dich kulturell weitergebildet, hast hast Weltoffenheit gelernt,
uns sehr, sehr viele unterschiedliche Perspektiven.
Und dann bist du irgendwann nach deinen, nach deinen zwanzigsten Semester, hast du das Studium abgebrochen oder mit so mit so einem Magister oder so was abgeschlossen, ne? Und dann warst du intellektueller,
dann hast du eine eine nachher promoviert zu irgendeinem völlig skurrilen Thema,
bis dann vielleicht irgendwann in so eine in so eine Position gekommen bei äh einem einem großen Blatt äh zu schreiben, äh keine Ahnung, Zeit oder Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung, wo du dann ähm
Leitartikel geschrieben hast, ja, weil du weil du irgendwann,
Weitblick entwickelt hattest durch dein durch deine durch deine universelle Bildung in in mehreren Fachbereichen, ja? Das ist jetzt mal so das Ideal dahingestellt. Und das, was genau jetzt das ist genau das, was jetzt fehlt, denn jetzt werden an den Universitäten,
sehr klar strukturierte vorgegebene Lehrpläne mit Modul hier und musste da und da darfst du aussuchen, ob äh jetzt äh den einen Schwerpunkt vertiefst oder den anderen, aber letztendlich werden das so gleich.
Sehr viel mit sehr viel weniger Freiheitsgraden ausgestattete äh Studiengänge, die sehr viel gezielter darauf abgehen,
äh dass du sie irgendwie zu einem Job machst, ja?
Es ist wirtschaftsorientiert, es ist nicht nicht forschungsorientiert, so dieses freie äh Forschen und dieses äh Freie Entwickeln, also insbesondere diese Freiheit der Wissenschaft spielt an der Stelle einen zunehmenden Maße äh weniger eine Rolle und das ist
ähm ja,
Es ist äh zu beklagen. So, ich meine, den Trend haben wir aber schon länger und das hat jetzt auch nicht unbedingt was mit der digitalen Agenda zu tun. Äh die wird da bloß auch nicht sehr viel helfen.
Das stimmt, aber es man sieht da auch Festgeistes Kind das ist äh diese ganze Angelegenheit ist, ja, eine Wertschöpfungskette von der Grund
Lagenforschung bis hin zu Transfer und Verwertung. Da werden sich die wenigen, die an irgendeiner Universität noch Grundlagenforschung betreiben dürfen, aber freuen, dass jetzt auf die Wertschöpfungskette geachtet wird.
Also ich sehe das schon äh,
Als Warnsignal, aber okay, die Uni, das dieses Bildungssystem in Deutschland ist jetzt gerade eh nochmal ein anderes Thema, aber das ist ja eins, was mich auch immer sehr kann ich mich auch drüber echauffieren, habe ich ja jetzt gar nicht,
Kommen wir zu meinem Lieblingsthema. Ähm.
Ja, die Sicherheit.
Die Sicherheit.
Raum.
Dieses haben sie Cyber-Raum geschrieben. Nein. Sicherheitsschutz und Vertrauen für Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft. Da kommen wir gleich nochmal ähm kommen wir gleich nochmal.
So ein schönes äh habe so ein schönes T-Shirt gesehen. Es war von von der Blackhead oder von der Defcorden, was nicht irgend so eine amerikanische Security-Konferenz,
irgendwie drauf stand.
Mit Semul Jackson, ne.
Ja, genau, genau, genau. Mit mit äh.
Das könnten wir ja der Bundesregierung auch mal vorhalten. Äh wie kann man jetzt mal bitte dieses dieses Präfix endlich mal fallen lassen? Es geht auch gar nicht. Cyber-Raum, das ist kein Cyber-Raum.
Shit, das steht ja echt da. Meine Güte.
Na ja, so ist das. Cybersicherheitsarchitektur, sowas wird jetzt hier äh gefordert. Mit Cyber-Abwehrzentren.
Ja ja, da wird als, da kommen wir ja gleich noch.
Crime, Cyber, Spionage und Cyber Security. Ich hätte dann aber auch gerne einen Cyber-Minister oder einen Cyber-Kanzler.
Cyber ganz lang.
Das wäre doch mal was. Cyber, Cyberflutzug durch die durch die World Cruisen,
Yeah.
Äh ja, ich möchte äh zur IT-Sicherheit kommen wir nachher nochmal, aber ich ich finde sehr schön, dass hier,
Sind auch immer so schöne entlarvende Sachen. Ich habe äh gestern mal kurz mit der Konstanze gesprochen,
die da also sagte, ja, die äh digitale Agenda wollen sie natürlich dann auch irgendwie mal in
bringen, ne? Auch wenn die das Ding durchlesen, wenn sie das wirklich im Neusprechfunk bearbeiten, ne, da können sie eher so eine Hörbuch-Edition draus machen,
so, ne? Der große Brockhaus.
In der Tat.
Na ja. Ähm okay, ähm ähm,
wichtiger Punkt hier ist, sie wollen jeden einzelnen in die Lage versetzen, jeden einzelnen in die Lage versetzen, sich selbst und seine Daten im Netz wirksam zu schützen,
wohlgemerkt selbst, ne? Ähm sie wollen modernen Datenschutz, aber sie wollen auch Chancen nutzen.
Also das war auch seit so vielen Jahren. Aber zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz kommen wir ja dann äh später nochmal. Deswegen äh.
Würde ich das, äh würde ich diese ganze IT-Sicherheit ein bisschen verschieben, aber was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, da sagen sie,
Das BSI soll mehr Geld und Personal bekommen und das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz soll mehr Geld und Personal bekommen. Das BSI um die äh Bürger und Unternehmen zu schützen, das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz zur Spionageabwehr. Da werden sie auf einmal ziemlich konkret.
Steht ganz klar, die kriegen mehr, so zack, Neuausrichtung, Cyber, Sicherheitsarchitektur, Mittel-Zackboom. Das ist der erste, wo du drüber stolperst und sagst.
Da werden sie auf einmal konkret,
Bildung und Forschung hast du einen kompletten Absatz ohne Absichtserklärung eigentlich drin, ja? Aber oder auch davor bei den digitalen Lebenswelten. Aber hier sagen sie auf einmal konkret, die brauchen mehr Geld.
Verbessern die sachliche und personelle Ausstattung der Sicherheitsbehörden und gleichen die technische und rechtliche Befähigung den jeweiligen Aufgaben an. Und Bundespolizei wird auch gestärkt.
Ja
Werden sie auf einmal sehr konkret.
Genau. Und das Strafrecht muss unbedingt ans digitale Zeitalter angepasst werden. Mhm. Vom Urheberrechtsziel wahrscheinlich nicht die Rede.
Nee, Uhr war recht, weil wir stärken die internationale Kooperation, zum Beispiel mit der europäischen IT-Sicherheitsagentur und dem Europol Cyber Crime Center. Europoper Cybercrime.
Sie sprechen übrigens auch davon, dass sie Strafbarkeitslücken bei der Datenheelerei schließen wollen.
Das bitte. Ist das sozusagen ihr Sicherheitsvorfall, den sie jetzt hier gerade äh beklagen?
Datenhelerei, also ich meine, Datenheederei, also so Dirk, wir kaufen,
klauen, Daten und verkaufen die. Das meinen sie doch. Ist das sowas wie die Steuer-CD, die sie in meiner Schweiz kaufen?
Fünfhunderttausend garantierte aktive E-Mail Adressen.
Klicken sie hier fünf Mark.
Deutschlands top top Steuersünder.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Es ist ja eh alles was. Na ja komm wir kommen.
Ich meine, aber auch der, da werden sie mal konkret, ja? Deswegen, frage ich mich gerade, was äh jetzt der Bereich Datenheelerei jetzt hier grad so eine Sonderrolle spielt so, hatte ich jetzt bisher noch nicht.
Kann man jetzt nicht mehr noch mal weiter drauf klicken, ja?
Hm
Naja, dann sagen sie, ähm genau, die sollen also mehr Geld kriegen und dann kommt noch der letzte Teil, das ist dann die europäische
und internationale Dimensionen der digitalen Agenda. Das soll natürlich alles irgendwie ein Netz ausbauen, Netzneutralität, Vollendung des digitalen Binnenmarktes. Da müssen wir alles erstmal,
äh mit der mit Europa drüber reden, so ungefähr, ja. Ähm.
Sagen letztendlich.
Sie wollen natürlich auch die Mitwirkung an an Prozessen zum Management des Internets in Klammer Internet Governance, da wollen sie sich dran beteiligen, beteiligen?
Und ein Völkerrechtes Netzes wollen sie weiterentwickeln.
Wir wollen Klarheit über das anwendbare Völkerrecht des Netzes herstellen, um die geltenden Grund- und Freiheitsrechte auch in der digitalen Welt wirksam zu schützen.
Und die Chancen für eine demokratische Teilhabe am weltweiten Kommunikationsnetz verstärken. Ich, also wir.
Die Beteiligung in der WWW Freedom Online Core Edition dot com. Ja, danke. Dann haben wir das ja jetzt auch dann also.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das hier noch wirklich noch so weiter äh treiben müssen, weil wir kommen hier nur von einem Wischiwaschi zu dem anderen. Was mich sehr viel mehr,
würde, was ja, was wird da jetzt in der in der nächsten Zeit konkret daraus abgeleitet werden, weil ich meine, sie werden das natürlich jetzt nicht ohne
Hintergedanken so formuliert und vorgestellt haben. Einerseits mag es ihnen natürlich darum gehen, den Eindruck zu erwecken, sie würden irgendwas tun. Auf der anderen Seite äh wollen sie sicherlich irgendwas auch tun
nur was hier jetzt eigentlich konkret äh wirklich tun wollen, geht aus diesen Dokumenten,
eingeschränkt, nur sehr eingeschränkt hervor, ja? Es ist äh kann im Prinzip alles genauso weiterlaufen wie bisher. Sie können immer noch sagen, haben wir doch gleich gesagt
ja oder irgendwelche Maßnahmen werden ergriffen, mit denen wir vielleicht noch gar nicht rechnen, aber ich denke, das ist irgendwie zu diesem Zeitpunkt einfach für uns auch irgendwie,
nicht so richtig das Fleisch, in dem wir uns äh ausreichend abarbeiten können. Was mir im Übrigen gerade eben erst aufgefallen ist, dass man ja tatsächlich die einzelnen Aspekte dieser äh sieben Kategorien, also.
Kann man nur mal anklicken, ja.
Äh kann man nicht nur nochmal anklicken, sondern kann man ja auch kommentieren. Sei es erschreckend wenig Kommentare zu finden.
Na, ich bin eher ich äh glaube, dass da erschreckend viele Kommentare äh der Moderation zum Opfer gefallen sind.
Ja das wäre ja dann nahezu alle, weil ich habe jetzt gerade mal so zwei bisher gefunden äh
besonders einladend scheint es irgendwie nicht zu sein, aber das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder als äh Vorreiter, Projekt der äh Auseinandersetzung und der öffentlichen Kommentierung oder Diskussionen mit
den.
Also es ist abschließend ist vielleicht zu sagen, also zu Datenschutz sagen sie irgendwie die in der EU festhängende Datenschutzverordnung soll kommen, ja?
Neutralität, sagen Sie nichts, außer, dass das wichtig ist und auf EU-Ebene besprochen werden muss, Urheberrecht, keine Nichts Klarstellung zur Störerhaftung, sehe ich nicht,
Ja? Da da sind einfach also die die Probleme, die sagen wir mal, wir als äh konkrete Probleme ähm identifizieren würden, ja? Werden dadrin noch nicht einmal äh angesprochen.
Außer natürlich der Breitband, die Breitbandsache, die jetzt für dich natürlich auch ein sehr konkretes Problem ist, was dich auch sehr viel beschäftigt. Und das finde ich auch richtig und wichtig, dass ähm selbst da haben wir also eine Lösung, die jetzt dich nicht ähm,
begeistert? Preadlove Saison.
Ja. Also ich würde ich würde ja schon die Wette abschließen, dass schon der Link auf das PDF-Dokument irgendwie in einem halben Jahr nicht mehr gültig ist.
Ähm,
Die Reaktionen waren so gemischt, gemischt, die IT-Branche war positiv. Alle anderen haben irgendwie gegähnt, äh der Rest ist eingeschlafen. Ähm,
Es war, gab halt viel Kritik daran, dass das ebenso absolut unklar ist, ne. Das ist irgendwie sowas wie,
Ähm und da fand ich heute einen sehr schönen, sehr schönen äh Punkt, wo jemand sagte, das ist genau Merkel,
Das ist einhundert Prozent Merkel, was bezeichnet wird äh als dieses Aufsicht fahren, ne? Sich nicht irgendwie auf langfristige Ziele ähm,
nageln lassen, schön immer schöne bunte Bilder irgendwie rausgeben, tolle Sprüche kloppen, da kann kann niemand kann da jetzt was gegen sagen, ja,
keiner steht jetzt auf und sagt in der digitalen Agenda steht was falsches, ne? Aber alle sagen, warum steht da so viel drin? Warum steht da so viel Bullshit drin? Und warum ist das alles so vage, ja?
Und ich frage mich ernsthaft, die Erwartungen, die sie damit wecken, egal bei wem. Die können sie doch überhaupt gar nicht treffen.
Gleichzeitig ist der Text aber so formuliert, dass wenn am Ende einer sagt, ey, was ist denn hier mit? Ihr wolltet doch hier äh digitales Engagement fördern. Dann werden die sagen, ja hier kannst du doch sehen, Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung hat letztes Jahr fünfzigtausend Euro
ausgegeben für für Infohefte wie Internet übern Cyber haben wir doch gemacht.
Ja ist immer das Gleiche.
Es ist immer das Gleiche, ja. Naja, also so viel zur digitalen Agenda, aber die muss natürlich jetzt irgendwie die müssen auf die mussten wir ja nun mal eingehen.
Was wir hiermit äh getan haben. Unsere Berichterstatterpflicht ist äh hiermit genügend erfüllt. Ich definiere das mal so.
Genau denn wir kommen ja jetzt zum nächsten Thema der dem nächsten großen Thema der Woche.
Dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ist jetzt quasi der Teil,
aus der digitalen Agenda zur IT-Sicherheit, der dann jetzt auch schon mal tatsächlich in einen äh Referentenentwurf äh gegossen wurde.
Der geht dann jetzt durch die Ressource und soll dann Ende des Jahres verabschiedet werden. Das ersetzte das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Bei dessen,
Vorstellung dann äh Thomas de Maizire sagte, was ich jetzt vorlege, was wir breit diskutieren wollen,
ist vergleichbar mit der Einführung von Sicherheitsgurten beim Auto in den siebziger Jahren. Und viele werden sich erinnern, wie unerhört sie das fanden und heute ist es selbstverständlich, meine Damen und Herren.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt die ganze Zeit ohne Sicherheitsquote durchs Internet gefahren.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt. Ne? Und jetzt kommt Thomas de Maizire und erklärt uns, wie wir die anziehen müssen,
und dass die verpflichtend sein müssen. Welches Ziel hat er sich gesetzt? Er will.
Ziel ist eine Verbesserung der IT-Sicherheit bei Unternehmen,
ein verstärkter Schutz der Bürgerinnen und Bürger in einem sicheren Netz, der Ausbau der IT-Sicherheit der Bundesverwaltung und in diesem Zusammenhang auch eine Stärkung von BSI und Bundeskriminalamt. Kleiner Exkurs,
ohne das zu wissen, dass sich irgendwie jemand ähm ernsthaft an einem IT-Sicherheits Gesetz äh bemüht.
Habe ich ja schon vor einiger Zeit, ich muss mal überhaupt gucken, wann das war. Das war, glaube ich, so im Mai. Das war während der Republika, habe ich ja einen kleinen äh Auftritt im Bundestagsausschuss digitaler Agenda gehabt,
wo ich ja dann einerseits äh mündlich Stellung genommen habe und andererseits schriftlich. Ähm,
wo ich dann mal so gesagt habe, was ich glaube, wie man jetzt so die IT-Sicherheit in Deutschland,
halbwegs erhöhen könnte, ja? Wobei ich ja dann auch immer nicht nur auf Deutschland blicke. Ähm das war,
Am siebten Mai habe ich das eingereicht, ne. Haben wir als CC äh habe ich auch nicht nicht nur alleine verfasst, habe ich natürlich auch Rat von äh von anderen Leuten äh eingeholt und haben wir gesagt, okay ähm,
letztendlich halten wir für sinnvoll,
dass man irgendwie die Qualität von Open Source Software sicherstellt. Regelmäßig Überprüfungen durchführt und vor allem dafür sorgt, dass man durch Backbountees.
Ähm also quasi auf Sicherheitslücken,
Kopfgelder aussetzt, also Belohnung aussetzt, darauf, dass jemand eine bestimmte Form von Angriff erfolgreich
auf eine auf eine Open-Source-Software durchführt, ja? Und das die Lösung ist ja dann immer, du lobst diesen
bauen die aus und wenn die Person den Angriff demonstriert und dir zeigt, wie man ihn loswird, beziehungsweise zeigt, wie der Angriff funktioniert hat, dann weißt du ja, wie du ihn losfährst, dann kriegt sie halt eine sehr hohe Belohnung
Das ist eine Verfahren, was in letzter Zeit sehr häufig zum Einsatz kommt
was ja auch Google inzwischen schon macht, die haben bestimmte Software auf der Liste für besonders kritisch, wo sie sagen, da zahlen sie für,
Sicherheitslücken ab einem bestimmten Niveau. Äh oder in bestimmten Formen von Angriff. Und,
Das hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass du eine Menge ähm Forscher hast, die,
in ihrer Freizeit oder so aus finanziellem Antrieb, dann Bugs in dieser Software suchen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip gehen ja mehrere Leute ins Rennen, aber nur einer wird am Ende die Belohnung bekommen.
Zumindest für einen Back.
Für einen zumindest für einen Bug, genau. Kann natürlich auch nach hinten losgehen, wenn du das auf die falsche Software machst, wo noch hunderte von Wachs drin sind, ne?
Also mach's halt. Bezahlt's halt erstmal so ein Audit, so und dann fängst du irgendwann sagst, okay, das Ding ist ausreichend gehärtet und dann erhöhst du vielleicht so langsam den Preis für die.
Ja? In der Hoffnung, dass dann eben jemand ähm, dass Menschen suchen. Erstens, und zweitens,
ähm die die was mehr Menschen suchen, ne. Das heißt, du hast dann
muss nur einmal, du musst nur eigentlich nur einen Audit bezahlen, ne? Und kannst halt davon profitieren, weil diese Backboundies natürlich auch immer nicht nur an an finanzielle Bezahlung gekoppelt sind, sondern eben auch an sowas, an sowas wie halt,
eine eine gewisse Ehre, ja? Also sagen wir mal, wenn das BSI jetzt wirklich ein Backbound hier auslobt auf eine besondere Software, sagen wir mal Open SSL oder sowas und du bist derjenige, der den gewinnt, ne, dann kann das BSI dir
noch dazu zu einer relativ großen Publicity verhelfen. Das heißt, das sind attraktive Angebote für für,
Auch für kleinere Unternehmen oder für Hacker, die gerade arbeitslos sind oder so, ne? Das ist wirklich was was Gutes. Haben wir vorgeschlagen. Und da haben wir gesagt, gleichzeitig wollen wir.
Für Anbieter von äh Sachen eine Haftung sicherstellen. Das ist eine Sache, die wird relativ,
breit immer diskutiert, da gibt's auch auf gute Argumente dagegen, ne, dass man sagt, für,
deine äh für deine Software, die du anbietest, kannst du im Prinzip gar nicht haften. Stelle dir vor, Microsoft müsste auf einmal für Sicherheitslücken in Windows haften.
Die fixen, die fixen jeden Dienstag zwanzig Sicherheitslücken in in ihrem Windows, ne? Die Frage ist aber natürlich die sind ja irgendwann mal da reingekommen.
Und das heißt ja, dass sie am Anfang sich nicht ausreichend darauf konzentriert haben, dass ihre Software äh sicher werden soll. Wobei Microsoft jetzt auch echt ein,
undankbares Beispiel ist, weil die wirklich natürlich in in den letzten ähm zehn, fünfzehn Jahren wirklich da äh massiv die Daumenschrauben angezogen haben. Aber natürlich hat diese Haftungsklausel noch ein anderes Prinzip, denn,
ähm sie soll natürlich auch kommerzielle Anbieter genau in diesen Open-Source-Bereich,
drängen, damit wir nämlich an den Punkt kommen, dass wir etwas produzieren, Software produzieren, die für alle da ist, ja, von der die gesamte Menschheit als solche äh profitiert, ja, wo ähm.
Was entsteht für was für die Menschen? Alle da ist und was für wovon die Menschen alle äh profitieren,
ja? Das muss ja etwas sein, was so einer Sicherheits ähm Politik zu Grunde liegt. Dass alle davon profitieren, ja?
Ein Unternehmen in der Lage ist ein Kanzlerinnenhandy herzustellen für für fünfzig ausgewählte Leute. Was dann auch geknackt wird von der NSA, weil es eben closed ist und und nicht nicht ausgegoren,
letztens mitm äh guten Freund drüber unterhalten, der Entwickler ist. Und der einfach mal sagte so, wie viele Mann Jahre stecken in diesem Linux-Körnel,
und da stehst du doch wirklich äh mit dieser schönen äh Berater äh Sprache. Da stehst du ja wirklich auf den Schultern von Giganten.
Dann haben wir gesagt ähm,
natürlich dezentrale Sicherheitssysteme fördern und endet zu Ende Verschlüsselung, Ausbauen, ja? Zentrale Strukturen sind immer wieder ein Problem in der IT-Security, starke Sicherheitsstandards umzusetzen,
kann nur das Ziel sein, ne, nur so kriegst du irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, dich gegen diese Massenüberwachung zur Wehr zu setzen
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung zum Standard machen
und natürlich dann auch den Betrieb kritischer Infrastruktur absichern. Das ist was, wo es gerade ein großes Defizit gibt. Ist jetzt nicht mein Fachgebiet, aber ähm,
Christian Haarsträubende ähm,
haarsträubende Screenshots andauernd von irgendwelchen Hackern, die gerade wirklich so ein Stadtwerk gehackt haben und der Tonkraftwerk gerade schneller oder langsamer drehen können, so ungefähr.
Brennstäbe rauf und runter fahren.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt, also das ist, ich das ist natürlich dann immer so die große Legende, aber äh du siehst auf jeden Fall irgendwie so ein Wasserwerk, wo du mal irgendwie die Pumpstände ablesen kannst, das das siehst du relativ schnell, wenn du dich da mal gegen die richtige Tür lehnst. Ähm,
Und dann natürlich, dass man sich überlegt, was so Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die ja immer auch ein Risiko sind, weil sie eben Sicherheit untergraben,
Dass man die einfach mal regelmäßig prüft, ja? Dass man sagt, ähm wir wollen schauen, ob diese Überwachungsmaßnahme, diese,
Diese gesetzliche Grundlage, die wir da geschafft haben, wirklich überhaupt ihren Effekt bringt, ja, dann wäre nämlich an sowas wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann nämlich auch gescheitert, weil es da ja keinerlei Evaluationen gibt, die sagen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat irgendjemanden etwas gebracht.
Ja? Naja und dann haben wir noch gesagt, was ein sehr wichtiger Punkt ist, den ich ja auch schon seit einiger Zeit kritisiere, dass BSI
unabhängig werden vom vom Innenministerium,
Ja, also solange das das Innenministerium einerseits äh im Rahmen seiner Überwachungs- und Strafverfolgung und sonst was Interesse daran hat, die Sicherheit der der Bürger zu unterwandern
kann das BSI im gleichen dem gleichen Hause untergestellt, nicht irgendwie was vernünftiges auf die Beine bringen, was jetzt ein Sicherheitskonzept wäre und genau da kommen ja dann auch so Sachen raus wie wie Demel,
Naja, auf jeden Fall das Ding, dieses Papier habe ich vor vor ein paar Monaten geschrieben,
Und dann wurde ich von der äh Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung vor zwei Wochen oder so nochmal gebeten, ähm.
Vorschläge nochmal zu schreiben für eine ähm,
für eine sichere sichere Zukunft der Kommunikation war so die Frage. Da habe ich im Prinzip das das Gleiche nochmal formuliert, aber auch ein bisschen bisschen eingängiger erklärt. Der Text war offensichtlich ganz gut, denn kurz darauf erschien er auf Heiser DE,
Stiftung alles unter CC bei veröffentlicht und da kann dann natürlich heiser einfach hingehen. Und das auch nochmal veröffentlichen, aber ist natürlich schön, ähm dass die Bird Stiftung so was auch macht, ne.
Ja, finde ich auch gut.
Ne? Und da habe ich dann gesagt, okay, habe ich im Prinzip das gleiche wiederholt, habe ich mal so ein bisschen erklärt, wie entsteht überhaupt eine Sicherheitslücke, ne? Warum ist überhaupt eine Sicherheitslücke in der Software? Und nur, wenn du das verstanden hast, kannst du dir ja überhaupt mal auf politischer Dimension überlegen,
wie du die rauskriegst,
oder wie du wie du vermeiden kannst, dass sie entsteht. Das hilft ja jetzt nicht, wenn nichts, wenn der, wenn der äh de Maizire hingeht und sagt, das wird jetzt alles sicherer, weil wir investieren äh in Sicherheit.
Sicherheit ist ja, Sicherheit ist ein Prozess, du kannst Sicherheit nicht kaufen. Oder einmalig installieren,
Ja, das ist ein wandelnder Prozess. Und da habe ich also mal ein bisschen so erklärt, Backdoors, Backdoors, absichtliche Schwächen
und äh bin da auch wieder zu dem Schluss gekommen, Open Source Software fördern, diesen Schwarzmarkt trockenlegen, der der für Sicherheitslücken besteht.
Da also das Beispiel mit den mit den Backbounties und dann eben auch eine offene Sicherheitskultur pflegen. Das ist übrigens ganz interessant,
das versuchten sie in dem in dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz auch,
und dann eben nochmal mit der unabhängigen Sicherheitspolitik das BSI herauslösen. Also ich habe da ein bisschen zu publiziert, wie man so schön sagt. Und ähm dann war ich natürlich besonders gespannt, als es jetzt hieß, wir machen IT-Sicherheitsgesetz.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich meine Meinung vorangestellt, so als die Forderung, die die die ich aufgestellt hätte und dann.
Bin ich natürlich sehr gespannt. Was davon ist jetzt in in das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz äh,
geschafft hat, das ja jetzt mit dem, mit der Einführung der der Kurzpflicht in den siebziger Jahren verglichen wird, ja?
Eigentlich relativ kurz. Sie sagen, wir wollen Mindeststandards für die Sicherheit von kritischer Infrastruktur.
Ja, welche.
Welche werden sie dann, werden sie dann sehen?
Aber bis heute baut erstmal Mindeststandards geben. Das ist doch schön.
Würde jetzt sehr wundern, wenn also da Mindeststandards äh da da fällt mir immer so dieses MBS Standards, das gibt's eigentlich für jedes System, hat dann irgendwann mal irgendeinen ähm Berater dann zusammengeschrieben so
Das ist auch man macht auch häufig Sinn. Ähm,
Die wachsen dann auch, also nicht ich finde das jetzt schön, dass sie das dann auch noch mal machen. Kritische Infrastruktur wird also jetzt in Zukunft sicher. Wie gesagt, da haben wir auch ein Problem in Deutschland oder wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur in Deutschland,
Und das ist schön, dass man sich dessen annimmt. Ich glaube nur nicht, dass das dass es jetzt mitm Mindeststandard getan ist, denn Mindeststandards sind kann man eigentlich bei allem voraussetzen.
Also der Begriff, der des Mindeststandards in der IT-Sicherheit ist so, ja, okay, Mindeststandard gehe ich davon aus. Aber du hast ja jetzt trotzdem noch hier diese ganzen Sicherheitslücken von den von den äh von den Dingern, die du dir dann darauf installiert hast. Aber okay.
Ja, das setzt ja auch vor allem das, also so ein Begriff wie Mindeststandard setzt ja im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen voraus, dass es äh alles immer so ohne Weiteres quantisierbar wäre.
Dass man irgendwie äh sagen kann, ja das ist jetzt genau so sicher und ab heute muss es ja noch mehr sicher sein. Da legen wir dann nochmal zwanzig Prozent drauf, ne, so ein bisschen so wie äh was
Hygienestandards im Restaurant, ja, was weiß ich, da gehst du dann mal mitm
Messgerät rüber und siehst halt irgendwie wie der Bakterienbefall äh so ist und wenn der halt irgendwie so und so viel Prozent äh überschreitet, naja, dann muss man da halt nochmal mit dem Reiniger rübergehen, dann ist der Mindeststandard durchgesetzt. Nur das Problem bei Sicherheit ist halt, dass du ja nie weißt, wie unsicher ist jetzt eigentlich gerade ist
und äh wie du schon so schön sagtest, äh ne, ist ja auch so so eine Binsenweisheit äh er ist ein Prozess, ja, ist kein Zustand, sondern ist halt ein Prozess, sondern muss er eben sich quasi dieser Mindeststandard quasi eigentlich auf
den Umgang mit dem Ziehen.
Was zum Beispiel der nächste Punkt, äh wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch tatsächlich schon äh abbildet, ne?
Ersetze, ersetze mindest einfach mal mit minimal,
ja? Das macht er wortbedeutet, tut er Bedeutung keinen Abbruch? Und dann siehst du auch schon,
das bedeutet, ne, also diese Mindeststandard, ein Mindeststandard wird ja überall ein Minimalstandard an Sicherheit wird ja überall vorausgesetzt und ähm,
Habe ja auch schon mal erwähnt, dass ich äh beruflich in in diesem Bereich tätig bin. Und diese Dinger, die schaue ich mir doch überhaupt gar nicht erst an,
Ist mir doch völlig egal. Ich gehe hin und hack das Ding und dann gucken wir mal,
Ja? Und bis jetzt hat noch kein Mindeststandard, den dann erfolgreichen Angriff verhindert. Na ja, okay.
Na gut, es sei denn, es ist halt ein Mindeststandard in der Art und Weise, wie man eben diese Prozesse macht, ne? Und da ist ja dann zum Beispiel diese Meldepflicht
äh wenn überhaupt erstmal äh bestimmte Sicherheitsschwankungen aufgetreten sind. Man kennt das, äh Firmen werden gehackt so, ab und zu geht mal einer an, dann tatsächlich an die Presse oder es kommt raus, dann stehen die natürlich doof da, weil alle irgendwie glauben, aha, ja, nur die und können die nicht aufpassen und jetzt sind da die Chinesen eingefallen,
betrifft das halt eigentlich die ganze Zeit alle, aber die anderen halten halt schön still, weil sie überhaupt nicht
diesen Eindruck äh erwecken wollen, sie wären jetzt in irgendeiner Form besonders gefährdet, auch wenn's letztlich alle sind.
Du hast äh, wenn du als Unternehmen irgendwie einen größeren äh größeren Sicherheitsvorfall hast und den hast du ja,
regelmäßig, ja, mal oder sagen wir mal, kleinere hast du regelmäßig, größere, hast du dann auch ab und zu mal. Ähm dann hast du sowas wie diesen Primärschaden.
Und den den sekundären Schaden, ja? Der sekundäre Schaden ist, wenn du wendet auf einmal in den Medien steht, dass du gehackt wurdest, ne?
Das ist der viel, viel, viel, viel schlimmere Schaden. Alles andere kannst du eigentlich in den Griff kriegen, aber dieser dieser äh oder sagen wir mal so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob's in allen Fällen der viel, viel größere Schaden ist, denn diese,
ist ja geduldig und die Leute vergessen das schnell. Aber es auf jeden Fall eine Vergrößerung des Schadens,
Weil alles was du wenn du gehackt wurdest, ob die Leute dich jetzt erpressen, diese Daten irgendwie der Konkurrenz geben oder was auch immer sie machen oder zu einem Ausfall führen von Systemen, die dich dann arbeitsunfähig machen,
der dich dann arbeitsunfähig macht. Wenn du damit jetzt noch in der Presse landest, wird der Schaden auf jeden Fall größer, als er schon ist.
Und deswegen hat er natürlich auch keiner Interesse dran. Und es gibt verschiedene Bemühungen ähm,
Und die gab es ja auch schon vom von dieser Cyberallianz. Die Cyberallianz für Deutschland macht das ja. Da setzt man sich dann alle in einen Kreis und sagt, dann ist man da scheint dann sowas zu sein wie, da sind dann so die Sicherheitsverantwortlichen, ne. Und,
dann gesagt so wie so wie bei,
stelle ich mir das dann so vor, ne? So, ja äh mein Name ist äh XYZ und ich bin äh Sicherheitsverantwortlicher bei einem DAX-Unternehmen. Und dann sagen alle, ja
Guten Morgen, XYZ, du bist sehr mutig, X Y Z und dann X Y Z, erzähl doch mal, wann ihr das letzte Mal gehackt wurdet,
Und dann sagt X Y Zelt natürlich so nö, also da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, bei uns, wir haben da eben also die Firewalls, die halten hier dick und äh ne, der, der, der, das, das
das Security-Dashboard immer alles im grünen Bereich, so ähm
Letztens erst wieder einen Teenager verhaftet, der versucht hat, auf unseren Onlineshop zu machen. Also da erzählt natürlich keiner was.
Weil diese ähm weil diese Atmosphäre eben auch nicht geschaffen wird dort. Und.
Jetzt frage ich mich aber auch, warum sollte da jemand was erzählen, ne? Wenn so ein Security-Breach passiert,
Dann haben die entweder also große Unternehmen haben ein Team, was den selber aufklären kann, selber die Forensik betreibt und das Problem löst.
Oder sie holen sich sofort irgendwelche äh äh Leute ins Haus von äh was weiß ich, wie heißen die Anbieter?
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein. Ist vielleicht auch besser, dass er mir nicht einfällt. Gibt's halt größere Berater, die man sich dann ins ins äh ins Haus holt, die machen dann die Forensik und die klären das auf, ne. Und ähm,
dann,
Ist die Sicherheitslücke ja weg. Du hast ja auch gar keinen Grund mehr, irgendeinem was zu erzählen, ja? Und wenn das in in irgendeiner Open-Source-Komponente war die Sicherheit schwächer, dann ist die auch in der weg. Ja, das heißt, es gibt für dich eigentlich keinen Grund mehr zu erklären.
Dich mit anderen darüber auszutauschen, als den, die irgendwie eine NDA mit dir haben,
Naja, aber die die Bundesregierung sagt, sie möchte das jetzt machen, weil sie ein Lagebild haben möchte, Lagebild ist ein wichtiger Begriff in dieser ganzen
Spionageabwehr, uns wird Lagebild. Ähm und sie wollen natürlich überhaupt erstmal Informationen haben, weil,
auch das äh weise ich aus äh verschiedenen Gesprächen, dass BSI jetzt im Moment nicht der erste Anlaufpunkt ist, wenn jemand gehackt wurde.
Ist es auch nicht. Ähm das heißt, äh das, was die Bundesregierung da weiß, weiß sie halt dann auch nur vom Hörensagen
sie wollen abgestimmt reagieren. Ich frage mich auch, was jetzt so eine abgestimmte Reaktion ist auf ein aufn Heck, aber äh das werden die schon wissen. Also der Cyber ist offensichtlich in vollem Gange
ähm,
und die Unternehmen sollen sich austauschen und äh geschlossen dagegen vorgehen. Wie gesagt, das ist keine schlechte Idee. Die Frage ist nur, du hast da halt soziale ähm,
wie nennt man das soziale Dilemmatal in solchen Austauschgruppen, ja? Dass nämlich du nicht weißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie quasi,
Hose runterziehst und sagst, wir hatten einen Vorfall von folgender Schwere und da habe ich sogar nochmal dreimal versagt, in dessen Behebung ähm,
profitieren da unter Umständen die anderen von. Du weißt aber auch nicht, ob die anderen davon profitieren?
Und du weißt auch nicht, ob die dir irgendwann mal etwas stecken, wovon du profitieren kannst. Ja, das heißt, das das ist wirklich eine eine schwierige, eine schwierige.
Man weiß sozusagen nicht, ob der so einen Tipp for Ted dahin äh kommt, dass jeder sozusagen zum Vorteil aller äh beiträgt. Mhm.
Das, was ich so höre, ist, dass das das ist jetzt der, dem BSi oder was oder in ihren Allianz für Cyber-Sicherheit, dann auch nicht gelungen ist, die ähm die die dort Anwesenden
von dem Sinn dieser ganzen Aufgabe zu überzeugen, ja? Das wäre natürlich was gewesen, wenn das BSI dann jemals an an die Leute herangetreten wäre und denen geholfen hätte. Aber das ist eben wohl auch,
scheint seltener vorzukommen.
Jetzt die Frage, was man den den Unternehmen denn irgendwie so anbieten könnte, dass sie sich da äh ermuntert fühlen, sich da äh dann zu machen.
Ja genau, zunächst wollen sie ihnen halt mal einen Zwang äh aufdrücken, ne. Es geht ja um eine Meldepflicht. Äh und dann sagen sie,
Und wenn ihr das nicht meldet, ne, oder wenn wir feststellen, dass ihr dann irgendwie nicht ordentlich mit umgeht oder irgendwie Sicherheitsprobleme nicht in den Griff kriegt, dann soll die Bundesnetzagentur, die ähm
das Recht bekommen, den Betrieb untersagen zu können,
ja? Interessanterweise zwei Sätze vorher sprechen sie noch davon, wie wichtig die Verfügbarkeit ist und weshalb diese Kommunikation grade Kommunikationsanbieter eben kritisch äh,
sind, ja? Und sagen, dass also unbedingt wichtig, dass du dass der, dass die Verfügbarkeit, ne, die muss immer Sicherheit sichergestellt werden. Stimmt ja auch. Und dann sagen sie als als Keule, als ultimative Keule wollen sie dann
soll dieses Bundesnetzagentur dann den Betrieb untersagen können. Das ist natürlich das ist natürlich auch lächerlich, ne?
Vielleicht nochmal kurz das bezieht sich aber im Prinzip alles jetzt auf das, was sie hier als kritische Infrastruktur definieren.
Äh noch nicht so nicht so äh nicht so explizit,
Also kritische Infrastruktur ist eben dieser dieser eigene definierte Bereich, für den sie eh schon alle möglichen Sicherheitsanforderungen haben, ne? Also wenn du kritische Infrastruktur bist, dann hast du halt erstmal ähm,
irgendwelche Prüfer im Haus, ja und äh Sicherheitsschwankungen, diese Meldepflicht für Sicherheits ähm äh,
Fälle wollen sie eher so für alles, was irgendwie größer Daten oder persönliche Daten oder Kommunikationsdaten handelt haben. Ja,
Sie wollen nämlich dann auch im nächsten Punkt äh besondere Sicherheitspflicht,
Besondere Sicherungspflichten für Kommunikationsinfrastruktur haben.
Und da sagen sie, da wollen sie nicht nur Inhalte und persönliche Daten wie bisher, sondern auch die Infrastruktur selbst schützen lassen,
ja? Und da fragst du dich natürlich auch, ich bitte dich, das eine Ding, was die die ganze Zeit, die Kommunikationsanbieter schützen, ist ihre eigene Infrastruktur,
Eine, was sie nicht brauchen, ist ein ist ein Gesetz zum Erhalt der Verfügbarkeit dieser Infrastruktur. Da ist ja ein unmittelbares Geschäftsinteresse dran,
gebunden. Ja, was sie, was sie nicht brauchen ist halt ein Gesetz für genau das.
So, wir verpflichten euch jetzt gesetzlich die Grundlage eures Geschäftes äh aufrechtzuerhalten,
ne? Inhalte und persönliche Daten, das ist natürlich ein Problem und da müssen sie viel, viel mehr äh Anreize für bekommen. Wenn man sich nur mal die Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland anschaut, das ist ja so ein kleiner kleines Ding, mit dem ich mich äh auseinandersetze,
Die sind halt äh zumindest zwei davon in einem äh wirklich katastrophalen Zustand. Da die kannst du ganz einfach, ganz problemlos abhören, dass du hunderte hunderte jetzt fange ich schon an wie,
andere Leute. Ähm da hast du mehrere ähm,
Möglichkeiten von Angriffen auf auf die äh auf die äh ähm Subscriber, die seit langer Zeit bekannt sind und die auch so weiterhin bestehen.
Das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel mal was, wenn man da sagen würde, okay, bekannte Sicherheitslücke muss,
innerhalb einer genannten Zeit geschlossen werden, ist eigentlich eine eine Selbstverständlichkeit,
auch grade wenn du jetzt so irgendwie anschaust wie so wie so Unternehmen irgendwie überhaupt ihre IT-Infrastruktur führen. Das machen die ja hauptsächlich nur dadurch, dass sie sagen.
Problem besteht,
oder Problem wird bekannt, wir messen die Zeit, wann das Problem weg ist und die Zeit, äh wenn die irgendwas Bestimmtes überschreitet, dann dann setzt es halt irgendwie richtig Ärger.
Und ähm genau das müssten sie natürlich hier an der Stelle machen, aber machen sie natürlich dann nicht.
Naja, also diese besonderen Sicherungspflichten ähm sehe ich da jetzt auch nicht äh wie die irgendwie jetzt für eine nennenswert zu einer nennenswerten Verbesserung führen sollen,
dann sagen sie, sie wollen das BSI für diese Cyber-Bedrohungslage rüsten, ja, denn es wir haben ja eine Cyberbedrohungslage.
Und das soll also hauptsächlich natürlich durch äh personelle äh personelle Stärkung ähm passieren,
und sie wollen also die bundes IT stärken durch verbindliche BSI-Vorgaben,
Das heißt, da kann das BSI sich dann wieder hinsetzen, braucht ein paar Jahre, schreibt ein schreibt eine Mindeststandard und äh durch mit diesem mittels dieses Mindeststandards wird dann die IT gestärkt.
Und auch soll das BSI jetzt mal ein Sicherheitskatalog für Telekommunikationsnetzbetreiber verfassen. Also Vereinige ist das natürlich ein Alptraum. Vereinige Telekommunikationsnetzbetreiber. Für andere ist das natürlich ein Witz.
Also da kannst du dir eigentlich, das das wird dann am Ende so funktionieren, dass das BSI zu dem,
zu den sichereren Telekommunikationsnetzbetreibern hingeht und sagt, legt mal euer Sicherheitskonzept offen,
und dann gehen sie zu den weniger äh vorbildlichen äh sicher äh Telekommunikationsnetzbetreibern und sagen, hier schreibt mal ab und setzt das mal um.
Und außerdem soll das BSI dann Warenbefugnisse bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie die sich das vorstellen, ja? Also ich meine, ähm.
Du kannst das ja so nicht durchsetzen. Du musst ja du musst halt einfach,
abstraktere und gleichzeitig konkretere Regeln verfassen, dass du nämlich sagst, okay, es gibt irgendwie drei,
Kritik, Kritikalitätsbereiche von der Infrastruktur, die ihr unterhaltet,
So und innerhalb dieser Kritikalitätsbereiche gelten grundsätzlich folgende Regeln. Äh eine bekannte Sicherheitslücke wird innerhalb von Zeiteinheit X entfernt. Punkt.
Sonst was weiß ich, Strafzahlungen, ja? Das wäre jetzt mal konkret,
Was meinst du wie schnell ähm irgendwie sage ich mal ähm Anbieter am unteren Preisspektrum und am unteren Sicherheitsspektrum mal eine äh ernst zu nehmende Verschlüsselung ausrollen würden in ihren Handynetzen?
Ja. Was immer noch ein echtes Problem ist, ne?
Nach wie vor, also nach wie vor, nur sehr, sehr langsame Veränderungen. Was
hält die Verschlüsselung an. Gibt's ja diese kleine Seite GSM Map, äh wo ich nicht ganz unbeteiligt dran bin. Da kann man sich dann mal so für die einzelnen Länder das anschauen. Ich will da jetzt gar nicht irgendwie einzelne Netzanbieter benennen, dass,
Eben Messungen, äh die veröffentlichen wir da, kann man sich anschauen. Ne, aber,
eben es gibt keine es es gibt bewusst irgendwie Verfehlung dann eben sanktionieren,
und irgendwie ein wahren Befugnis des BSI. Ich bitte dich,
Na ja, konkreter werden sie dann noch beim BKA. Das soll natürlich für die Cyber-Bedrohungslage gerüstet werden, genauso wie das BSI. Und da sagen sie wollen eine,
zentrale Meldestelle verbunden ist, für Angriffe auf Bundeseinrichtungen und Angriffe auf kritische Infrastruktur haben. Das ist dann so eine leichte Ausdehnung der BKA Zuständigkeit, die damit einhergeht. Denn das das BKA,
soll also jetzt so für alles, was irgendwie IT-Angriffe ist, dann äh zentral verantwortlich sein,
Das machen jetzt in bestimmten Bereichen halt noch LKAs ähm und,
eben in in vielen Fällen, wenn das jetzt nicht meldepflichtig unbedingt ist, machen das die Unternehmen dann eben auch auf eigene Forst oder eben Leute, die sich damit auskennen.
Das heißt, das wäre im Prinzip auch eine konkrete Änderung der Zuständigkeitssituation, was LKA, BKA betrifft. Ist es das, was du daraus liest?
Das lese ich das lese ich da raus äh oder beziehungsweise das jetzt überhaupt, als man die die BKA Zuständigkeit klar definiert wird. Und.
Bin mir jetzt komm mal wieder in diese äh Ecke. Nicht ganz sicher, wie jetzt da die die
melde und Hierarchiepflicht für solche Cyberangriffe ist. Aber ich meine, grundsätzlich kannste kannst du das natürlich ganz einfach zur Anzeige bringen
und alles, was jetzt Bundeseinrichtungen und kritische Infrastruktur ist, da soll das BKA jetzt eine Zuständigkeit für bekommen und eine zentrale Meldestelle. Ich wundere mich allerdings,
ob das irgendeine Änderung am Status quo mit sich bringt,
ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass sowas vorher nicht bei irgendwie letztendlich beim, beim BKA gelandet ist.
Also wenn wir jetzt wirklich über Hackerangriffe reden, ne. Das kann ja nur beim BSI oder beim BKA landen. Bei wem soll's denn sonst gelandet sein vorher? Bei irgendwie bei der bei der äh bei der Polizeidienststelle irgendwie Dienstlaken Süd oder was?
Aber die würden sich aber wundern,
Wichtig ist natürlich auch noch, dass äh der Verfassungsschutz äh gut ausgestattet wird. Ist ja übrigens neben der digitalen Agenda äh jetzt hier auch quasi in diesem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Man hat so das Gefühl, dass es irgendwie auch alles letzten Endes auf demselben Mist gewachsen.
Das ist es, aber aber lass noch mal, da muss man den Zusammenhang nochmal herstellen. Also die digitale Agenda also die die das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ist der erste konkrete Schritt zur Realisierung der digitalen Agenda.
Nach dem Motto, wir müssen jetzt mal was mit dem Internet machen. Äh Thema eins, hier Sicherheit und Verfassungsschutz. Na super. First think.
Und da wird eben,
Genau und da sagen sie jetzt halt, ja, Spionageabwehr offensichtlich ein Problem, Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz fünfundfünfzig neue Stellen. Dafür brauchen sie knapp viereinhalb Millionen Euro für zweitausendvierzehn und dann vier Komma zwei Millionen Euro in den in den Folgejahren.
Also ein bisschen mehr Mittel. Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, das finde ich ja sehr interessant. Ich hatte mich da ja, hatte ich, glaube ich, auch schon mal erwähnt, mit dem.
Doktor Bockhard Ewen mal unterhalten, das ist der Leiter der der Spionageabwehr beim Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz.
War dann also in diesem Gespräch sehr äh betonte immer, ja, ne. Also von den Amerikanern wisst ihr jetzt ja gar keine, gar keine Wirtschaftsspionage, gar nicht, nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Spinage äh von den Amerikanern, gar nicht äh
und ähm ja also wann, dann würde er die Angriffe immer nur aus China sehen und dann habe ich ihn halt gefragt, was was er sich denn so vorstellt.
Wie er sich denn so sicher sein kann, dass die, dass die Amerikaner das nicht machen, ne. Und dann sagt er, ja, also die hätten ja überhaupt gar keine Motivation dazu.
Dann habe ich ihn mal gefragt, ob ob er schon mal in Detroit war bei der US Automobilindustrie.
Angeschaut hat, wie die da äh wieder irgendwie leere Fabriken äh die die Obdachlosen, ehemaligen Arbeiter beherbergen und wie bei keinem Fahrzeug, was die USA produzieren, auch nur irgendein Spaltmaß erhältlich stimmt
na ja. Also die kriegen jetzt irgendwie fünfundfünfzig neue Stellen. Man kann da nur hoffen, das kann nur zu irgendeiner Verbesserung führen. Man weiß jetzt natürlich nicht, ob diese Verbesserung in irgendeinem.
Zusammenhang steht äh zu dem, was sie da sagen, ne. Also ich meine, dem Verfassungsschutz, ausgerechnet der Behörde, noch mehr Geld zu geben,
Ist natürlich ein eine mutiger Schritt. Ja, also die haben jetzt wirklich nicht geglänzt in den in den letzten.
Ja kann man nicht sagen.
Wenn ich schon mal zitieren darf, die, die wie kaum eine andere Behörde, für das Gegenteil von Sicherheit stehen, die, die den Ku-Klux-Klan Deutschland,
den Kuckucks-Clan Deutschland, den NSU und andere verfassungsfeindliche Organisationen entweder selbst gegründet und oder jahrelang Performannspender am Leben gehalten haben,
ausgerechnet die werden jetzt nicht zugemacht, sondern kriegen auch noch neue Planstellen dazu. Und dann nennen sie das auch noch Sicherheitsgesetz.
Schön gesagt.
Wenn das nicht unsere Steuergelder wären, wäre es fast eine schöne Aktion zum Montypiven Abschlusstour.
Hm
Ja, bringt uns das dann auch schon zu dem anderen drei Buchstabenabkürzungsorganisationsteil.
Ja, wir sind endlich beim BND.
Der kriegt übrigens nur deshalb nicht mehr Geld, weil er dem Kanzleramt äh äh untersteht. Ja, also deswegen äh steht hier nicht, dass der BND mehr Geld kriegt. Das kommt also im im anderen.
Ne, nicht Teil des Internets.
Phase. Die gehen bei einer anderen, die gehen dann an anderer Stelle, äh kriegen die dann noch ihre Ausschüttungen.
Ja, aber ich habe gehört, der BND, der performt total jetzt irgendwie. Ja, also äh das ist äh erstaunlich, ne, also der der Nachrichtendienst, der sozusagen dafür zuständig ist, im Ausland äh für Nachrichten zu sorgen,
jetzt im Ausland für Nachrichten gesorgt und das ist ein totaler Skandal, weil äh ihm jetzt sozusagen Tätigkeit nachgewiesen wurde.
Ja, es gibt einen Tätigkeitsnachweis des BND. Es gibt.
Man hat sich ja immer gefragt, ja, ob die überhaupt schon mal irgendwas abgehört haben. Aber äh man weiß sich nicht so sicher. Und jetzt äh Shocking News, ja, sind also so enge, äh warmherzig mit äh unserem Land verbundene Länder
wie die Türkei tatsächlich in den Fokus geraten. Ja, also das ist ja gerade zu überraschend.
Ja, seit zweitausendneun führt der Bundesnachrichtendienst ähm die Türkei als Aufklärungsziel,
Ähm die Regierung legt üblicherweise alle vier Jahre so schwerpunktsziele fest für den für den BND
Und äh das haben sie aber jetzt wohl irgendwie die die Schwerpunkte seit zweitausendneun haben sie dann zweitausenddreizehn nicht erneuert, deswegen sind die noch so in, in, in Kraft. Und ähm.
Ja, die Türkei. Ja, ähm.
Ganz ehrlich äh sehe ich jetzt wenn ich mir anschaue, was da gerade in der Regierung los ist, äh finde ich, da finde ich das gar nicht so schlecht,
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Skandal, weil das ein NATO-Partner ist. Und ist natürlich eine völlig bescheuerte, steilvorlage für die äh USA, ne?
Also wenn die wenn die wenn die äh wenn der BND irgendwie die die Türkei irgendwie als als Aufklärungsziel führt.
Als NATO-Partner, wieso sollte dann die USA ähm da irgendwie ähm Hemmungen haben gegenüber anderen Ländern, zumal ja.
Nieren unter Freunden, ja, ich meine, das geht ja nun wirklich gar nicht.
Nee unter Freunden geht das gar nicht.
Unter Freunden geht das gar nicht. Zum Beispiel, was ja völlig, völlig wahnsinnig wäre, wenn jetzt der BND auch noch so Hillary Clinton abgehört hätte, ne?
Im Rahmen einer Operation gegen Terrorverdächtige im mittleren Osten hat es dann irgendwie ein kleines bisschen Beifang gegeben.
Beifang. Ne, Beifang, das hatten wir irgendwann schon mal vor einiger Zeit, Beifang im Datenschlapp schleppen. Jetzt war, glaube ich, ein schöner, einer Logbuch. Da gab's jetzt tatsächlich hier Beifang im Datenschlepp, Netz im mittleren Osten.
Ja, da zappelte auf einmal so ein US-Amerikanische Delfin, so mitten, so in so einem islamischen Herings äh Meute. Äh.
Aber die zuständige Fachabteilung hat natürlich unverzüglich die BND-Spitze über den Vorgang informiert,
und die hat eine kurze Prüfung, also hat sich das einmal angehört und hat dann die Vernichtung des Mitschnitts und des Transkripts angeordnet,
ja? Und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der Oberknaller. Haben sie gesagt, das muss jetzt vernichtet werden. Ja, und diese Vernichtung,
Mit der Vernichtung wurde dann Markus R beauftragt. Dieser ähm Typ im Archiv, der sich jetzt vor einiger, vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten da als als ähm als Spitze der Amis herausgestellt hat,
und der hat dieses Transkript dann natürlich irgendwie mit an die ähm an die an die Amis gereicht. Und wie die jetzt überhaupt.
Wussten, ne.
Genau und jetzt da stand da glaube ich in der Artikel nicht explizit, aber das kann man sich eigentlich zusammenreiben, dass ähm die ja bei der Hausdurchsuchung bei dem,
eine ähm einen USB-Stick mit irgendwie den zweihundert noch was Dokumenten, die der,
den Amis gegeben hat, gefunden haben. Und da scheint sich jetzt einer einmal dieser Mitschnitt von dem Hillary Telefonat und andererseits eben die Information, dass sie die Türkei überwachen, beziehungsweise also diese Schwerpunktziel,
Zusammenfassung. Das schien also beides in dessen äh in dessen äh ja in dessen Beute äh gewesen zu sein. Und dadurch kommt das jetzt an die Sonne, ja.
Also ich meine, man wird ja jetzt sagen, so man, das ist doch schön, dass die auch mal was abgehört haben. So können denen das doch mal, ne.
Die Frage ist jetzt überhaupt, wer regt sich jetzt gerade eigentlich worüber auf? Also äh haben wir jetzt eine Aufregung der Öffentlichkeit? Haben wir eine Aufregung der äh Bundesregierung, haben wir eine Aufregung der Türkei? Gab's da eigentlich irgendwelche Rückmeldungen,
weiß ich gar nicht. Ich meine, man kann ja nur nicht gerade sagen, dass äh Angela Merkel und äh Erdogan äh ja in einer in einem geschwisterlichen Verhältnis zueinander stehen würden,
Wahrlich nicht, ne und äh von daher ist, glaube ich, auch keiner so richtig überrascht und davon überrascht zu sein, dass der BND tatsächlich seine Aufgaben wahrnimmt, äh kann man ja nun eigentlich auch nicht sein.
Nö, also ist.
No News.
Wie wie wir schon immer sagen so, nein, die anderen ähm.
Die also die anderen, also die Bundesregierung macht das genauso. Die Bundesregierung spioniert genauso. Ähm das ist alles eine sehr ähm,
Heuchlerische, ein sehr heuchlerischer Argumentationsweg, den sie sich in dieser äh ganzen äh NSA,
Sache äh verschrieben haben. Und der bricht natürlich jetzt auch zusammen und das war wurde auch mal Zeit. Ja, die stellen sich da hin und äh blähen die NSA. Ähm,
regen sich da irgendwie drüber auf, äh vollen irgendwie nicht klar äh zugeben, dass sie mit denen kooperieren. Wollen irgendwie nichts klar zugeben, dass die eigentlichen Opfer in dieser Angelegenheit natürlich wir,
als als
Zielpersonen sind, als Opfer dieser Massenüberwachung, sondern konzentrieren sich darauf, dass irgendwie Angela Merkels Handy abgehört wurde. Und jetzt kriegen sie natürlich gesagt, ja, macht ihr doch auch
ja. Übrigens hat die Hillary Clinton ja mit anderen äh telefoniert, ne, ist ja auch kein äh keine keine unbedeutende Person. Ähm,
und andererseits ist es natürlich leider so, dass jetzt die, ich glaube, der, die,
Deutschen sich wahrscheinlich auch jetzt natürlich denken, achso, das sind ja ähm ja, das ist ja auch die Türkei.
Weiß man ja auch, dass da grade äh mit der Demokratie jetzt irgendwie nicht so so genau genommen wird.
Nö, nicht so besonders
Ja, ich meine, das ist alles nicht überraschend. Meine Türkei ist jetzt nicht nur, ich weiß ja nicht, äh genau, was jetzt die äh Motivation war, die Türkei da in den Mittelpunkt äh der Aufklärungsarbeit zu stellen zweitausendneun. Da hat sich das ja, sagen wir mal, noch nicht in dem Maße abgezeichnet, wie jetzt auch. Ich denke, das wird zu dem Zeitpunkt sehr viel mehr
mit der Lage Nahe Ost Kurden Problematik et cetera primär zu tun gehabt haben
vielleicht, vielleicht auch nicht, ja? Vielleicht gibt's ja auch irgendwelche äh Wirtschaftsspionage-Aspekte an der Stelle. Ja, wissen wir auch nicht.
Wissen wir alles nicht.
Da ist äh da da fehlt mir jetzt der äh der globalpolitische Weitblick ähm und auch vielleicht ein bisschen die Fantasie. Also mir fehlt ja eh die Fantasie, warum die äh also.
Diese diese ganze Spioniererei, ja, also was es.
Gibt ja, na, warum sie's machen, ist, also bei dem Preis, der da inzwischen investiert wird und die die Menge, in der das äh geschieht,
Gerade wenn's dann um Massenüberwachung der Bevölkerung geht, da ähm sehe ich im Moment.
Die Massenüberwachung
regt eigentlich bei niemandem wirklich irgendeinen das das wird einfach als Problem in dem Maße überhaupt nicht gesehen. Sondern diese ganze spioniererei ist halt einfach ein Rüstzeug der internationalen Diplomatie, umso mehr du weißt, was die anderen denken, umso besser kannst du da deine Interessen durchsetzen
so wird es zumindest erträumt, inwiefern sich das dann in der Summe für alle anderen abzeichnet ja, oder den einzelnen, weiß ich,
weiß ich nicht, ja, ist er aber halt einfach so. Also wie der Post hier, das neulich schon so schön zusammengefasst hat, ja, also der primäre Grund für Geheimdienste sind die Geheimdienste der anderen. Und äh
so dreht sich das halt einfach immer weiter im Kreis. Es ist einfach ein Wahnsinn, denen diese Welt einfach ausmacht. Und ich habe da ehrlich gesagt wenig Hoffnung, dass ich da in den nächsten hundert Jahren irgendwie groß was dran ändern wird.
Ja, wir haben so eine so eine.
Das werden wir sehen. Aber jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall dann unser Geheimdienst auch mal eine Kerbe im.
Na ist doch schön. Ja, äh trotzdem ist es irgendwie wirklich hier, also das hier geht wirklich jetzt in die Geschichte von Lokbuchen Netzpolitik ein, als die Sendung der der totalen Nicht-Nachrichten. Ja, also irgendwie haben wir bisher nur vollständige Nicht-Nachrichten gehabt,
Und jetzt kommen wir zu der letzten Nicht-Nachricht.
Das ist.
Oder? Ist es doch auch eine eine totale eine Nachricht.
Ja
Keinerlei keinerlei äh Informationswert hat, ja, also Holio A Sanchez, ja, auch unter seinem Künstlernamen Julian Assange bekannt
hat ja verkündet, dass er nun endlich nach zwei Jahren in der Diaspora, dieser Botschaft in London äh gedenkt, selbige zu verlassen
Ganze, als es irgendwie buchbar wurde, dass diese Verkündung ansteht, wurde dann auch noch irgendwie so merkwürdig äh von äh Meldungen über einen schlechten Gesundheitszustand, der dann aber irgendwie dementiert wurde. Das ist ein solcher Vorlege.
Äh aber auf jeden Fall war er der Meinung, dass es jetzt da nochmal gut wäre. Er würde jetzt gerne auch mal sich wieder die Beine vertreten wollen und äh wird halt dann bald,
Ja, das schöne Wörtchen wurde dort äh genannt als Zeitankündigung. Äh äh genannt. Und er würde dann halt irgendwie,
sich wohl, ich weiß nicht wie genau, ich habe diese ähm hast du die Pressekonferenz gesehen? Hat der hat der hat er denen gesagt, dass er sich sozusagen in die,
Äh
Großbritanniens da äh begeben wollen würde. Ich meine, darauf wird's zwangsläufig hinauslaufen, weil in dem Moment, wo er das Treppchen runtergelaufen kommt, dann wird er definitiv empfangen und erstmal irgendwo hingefahren. Und dann ist eigentlich weitgehend unklar, was dann passieren wird.
Der äh Polizist steht direkt an der Tür, der kommt noch nicht mal bis zur Treppe. Also,
der wird natürlich sofort in äh in England erstmal wegen Verstoß gegen seine Auflagen da dran sein. Die haben doch jetzt irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie viel,
Millionen Pfund dafür ausgegeben, dass da den ganzen Tag einer mit einem Maschinengewehr vor der Tür steht, mit einer Maschinenpistole vor der Tür steht. Ähm.
Äh lassen die sich doch jetzt nicht irgendwie wenn der da jetzt rausgeht, dann,
dann wird ja der Typ mit der Maschinenpistole jetzt nicht irgendwie einfach dann das Ding wieder in seinen Geigenkoffer packen und nach Hause gehen. Der wird ja, also natürlich wird er den festnehmen. Natürlich werden die dem irgendwie äh tierisch äh auf den Geist gehen damit.
Also mir ist völlig unklar, was was diese was diese Pressekonferenz sollte. Völlig unklar. Kurz davor.
Ja er sprach ja dann davon, dass irgendwie die die die Briten müssten ja dann auch irgendwie ihre war die Formulierung, ihre Zusagen, Zusagen müssen sie ja, müssten ja zusagen.
Also es klang so als.
Er da einfach raus kann oder so.
Ja, ich will, keine Ahnung, erstmal äh macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als hätte da irgendwie dann einen Höllenhebel in der Hand, mit denen er die ihn dann zu irgendwelchen Zusagen bringen kann, aber ich glaube, die werden sich mal mit Zusagen schön zurückhalten, ne.
Halte das für unwahrscheinlich, dass die dem irgendwelche Zusagen machen, nachdem nachdem sie den da irgendwie stundenlang äh seit seit zwei Jahren oder was mit einer mit einer mit Waffengewalt bewachen,
Ja? Und nachdem er gegen.
Was dem zusagen ist, dass er eine Menge Ärger kriegt.
Ja
Das war die einzige Zusage, die sie jetzt wirklich konkret machen können, ne.
Weiß auch nicht, ob das jetzt irgendwie so eine Finte sein soll oder oder ob er da irgendwie versucht, die die
die die öffentliche Meinung in irgendeiner Form einzuholen oder äh ob er da die schwedische Regierung hinzuzwang bringen will, irgendwelche Aussagen zu machen. Ich glaube, das einzige, was sie gesagt haben, ist, dass sich in ihrer äh Sicht bisher nichts geändert hat.
Da gab's ja auch nochmal irgendwann so eine so eine Anhörung. Ähm,
wo dann äh wo's dann um die Frage ging, ob die ähm.
Ob die Charges gegen ihn jetzt irgendwie noch aufrechterhalten würden, ja. Da gab's ja irgendwie so eine Verhandlung oder so eine Bekanntmachung und da haben dann die schwedische ähm Staatsanwaltschaft gesagt, ja klar, der soll hierher kommen,
der der ist eines äh eines eines relativ schweren Vergehens hier angeklagt worden.
Ist ja nicht wirklich angeklagt worden, sonst sind ja nur äh.
Angezeigt worden. Ja oder sie.
Sozusagen Ermittlungen äh irgendwie äh,
keine wirkliche Anklage. Das ist ja sozusagen auch das Besondere daran. Und man würde sich ja ganz gerne mal mit ihm unterhalten oder war das auf das Angebot, sich mit ihm zu unterhalten, nämlich per fern äh,
Konferenz, was man ja durchaus hätte tun können, also ich sehe zumindest keinen Grund, warum man das jetzt nicht hätte tun können. Ähm.
Keiner eingegangen.
Ja äh äh das wollten sie ja auch nicht, also das ist das ist einfach hier, hier spielen auch wirklich alle total irgendwie Fischi. Ich meine, was
mit dem Kenntnisstand den Holio eigentlich hätte haben müssen oder wo man zumindest den Eindruck hat, dass er ihn hätte haben müssen. Damals der Meinung war, er wäre nun ausgerechnet in Großbritannien sicherer als in Schweden, ja? Das erschließt sich mir ja nun auch wirklich nicht so richtig.
Ja ja, aber da.
Alles total unklar.
Ich bin mal gespannt, also ich äh,
Was soll sich geändert haben, dass er jetzt auf einmal meint, er könnte da raus gehen, ja? Vielleicht haben im Rahmen dieser dieser komischen Anhörungen, gab's irgendeine Akteneinsicht, dass sie jetzt wissen, okay, aus der Nummer mit der ähm,
mit den mit den beiden äh Damen, die sich da beklagt haben, kommst du raus oder so, dass er äh dass er sagt, okay er will sich der Angelegenheit stellen,
oder ob er vielleicht auch irgendwie inzwischen nur noch ähm ja auch vielleicht ein bisschen matt geworden ist im Kopf.
Vielleicht hat er irgendeine grandiose, geniale äh Taktik, zu der irgendwie diese äh Pressemitteilung gehört, aber ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen.
Wir wissen's nicht. Wir wissen's nicht.
Ja, du hast Recht. Wir haben jetzt wahrscheinlich echt die langweiligste Sendung gemacht, die wir je gemacht haben, ne.
Großartig, oder? Damit kann man doch eine Sommerpause beenden.
Ich habe das echt, ich habe echt Angst gehabt, also ich ich habe äh ich wollte jetzt nicht zu sehr irgendwie äh da mich drüber schrottlachen über diesen ganzen Kram und sagen hä also ich war bemüht, das irgendwie ernst zu nehmen.
Ja, das hast du ja auch wirklich gemacht. Trotz alledem bin ich jetzt irgendwie kein, ich bin kein Deutsch schlauer geworden irgendwie aus dem, was er jetzt irgendwie kommt. Also ich habe so nicht den Eindruck, dass irgendwas wirklich passiert ist.
Und ich glaube dadurch, dass ich das ernst genommen habe, bin ich dümmer geworden.
Oh Gott. Vielleicht war das ja der Plan.
Glaube echt, dass ich jetzt dümmer bin.
Oh Gott.
Fahre ich hier, sitze ich hier, weil wir wir hören auf. Ich kann auch nicht mehr. Hier ist Bullenhitze.
Bett, genau. Bullenhitze, du musst ins Bett und äh das schon am frühen Morgen. Wir äh sagen äh tschüss bei allen und äh danke für alles und äh bis.
Sorry.
Nee, so, sorry, nächste Woche wird's wieder spannend. Ciao.
Tschau, tschau.